this morning in our saturday session the
icelandic group of monsters and men they
first broke through in their home nation
after winning a music competition
then came the world when they recorded
an album that spun two international
hits we'll hear them perform in just a
moment but first ben tracy traveled to
iceland to hear their story as they
celebrate a decade since their
breakthrough success
[Music]
at their studio outside reykjavik the
five members that make up of monsters
and men are trying out a new version of
an old hit
[Music]
in 2011 the song little talks got a lot
of people talking about an unknown indie
folk band from iceland i have like a
really fond memory of that time
and
i i really enjoy going back to that
nana hilmer's daughter and ragnar
thorelson
are the band's lead singers and writers
it was a really great night we met them
at the music hall where they held their
first album release party
why did you decide to re-release the
album ten years later we've been wanting
to find ways to celebrate this because
we're very bad by the way at celebrating
yeah because you kind of have to be
grateful for it an album that put us
like in the situation we're in now and
gave us a lot so i think it deserves a
little birthday
[Music]
that album 2011's my head is an animal
also included the monster hit
dirty paws
[Music]
in 2012 just as their music was hitting
the airwaves in the u.s
the band traveled 4 000 miles to austin
texas to play the south by southwest
music festival where they played at a
bike shop
a lot has been made of the fact that you
went in there basically in a van and
left in a tour bus yeah yeah well yeah
that and it's kind of what happened
with two number one hits they toured for
two straight years the crowds captivated
by their unique blend of folk and pop of
monsters and men even bested bjork
iceland's other famous musical export to
become the first icelandic band to hit
one billion plays on spotify
[Music]
how much of the feeling of iceland and
what you see here do you think inspires
your music
i think a lot
we are very inspired by nature we do a
lot of these like
big moments and it's quieting down it
can go fast and slow just kind of like
nature can go a little more wild
yes and unpredictable
[Music]
their sound has evolved over the course
of three studio albums and now as they
re-release the original
[Music]
they've included a new single phantom
that was originally meant to be on it
but i
feel that
[Music]
it's like this beautiful sadness in that
song i wrote it when i was 16 years old
it's been with me like
half of my life like i've always had
like a very melancholic spirit you know
i am quite drawn
to sadness in a way
like i think it can be really pretty
but there is only joy in remembering how
far they've come
the group had just formed in 2010 before
winning iceland's battle of the bands i
remember being very nervous super
nervous
here at the reykjavik art museum did it
feel in the moment like it was going
well
um no
not for me so you did not expect to win
no no i think it's kind of like we never
expect
anything good to happen even though this
message i was like you're wearing the
wrong shirt for that kind of life model
well maybe maybe i've changed a bit you
know
[Music]
with time perhaps a bit more optimistic
and willing to take time to celebrate
it doesn't necessarily mean that it goes
on forever it can you know stop like
this
yeah you just you enjoy it and
appreciate it